first
good afternoon fellow councillors of the
public
the media
welcome to the meeting of august 2022
your worship
um
oh thank you
you remain outstanding please for the
council prayer
almighty god grant to us all needed
guidance
wisdom and judgment as we face the tasks
before it
can enable us now
and always
worthy to discharge the sacrifice
thanks by the people in their hands
thank you we've got an apologies from
council of scout
councillor abbott who comes in
and
i'll second that your worship
minutes of the meeting of council
out on the 26th of july
2022. i'll move those your worship i'll
see how your worship second any
discussion questions
put it to the back of the favor and say
hi
minutes of the black community called
meeting held on
first of all just 20 22.
i'll move those minutes to worship
second did your worship
recommendation to
council
jefferson's report
2024
funding request
that council
approved the spending of
up to 15 000
for
information boards
i'll move that way your worship
i'll second that
second
discussion
is
august 2022
be received happy to move those who
worshipped
and partnerships committee
meeting on the 9th of august 2022
i'll move that the minutes are confirmed
your worship
i'll check in that you wish
thank you
recommendations to council
thank you your worship the
recommendations are there as noted
in
the agenda i'm happy to move
second that your worship
moved in second
discussion
questions
control
which incorporates the following
changes
do you worship we've just uh we've just
moved those
yes
deliberations on keeping with animals
pulsing
and bees
to adopt keeping with animals poultry
can be vital
simple process you worship happy to move
that it's adopted second that you
worship
you worship i did notice that council
rabbit had his hand raised just a moment
ago
yes sir thank you for that um it's just
your worship you're very very hard to
hear everybody else is quite clear and
distinct but you're very very
muted on your microphone
sorry is that better yes much better
thank you
i'll put that um
[Music]
there's number eight then submission to
environment southland on the draft
british border visions
to be moved to council
one received the report
submissions on to
environment southland on the draft
british water visions
and to
confirm the submission noting that it
was submitted
to environment southland
by the closing date of the 19th of
august 2022
oh god
um i don't know it's been moved yet you
worship and briennen's here in case
anyone wishes to ask any questions
yes welcome to the meeting
thank councillor clark
councillor clark yeah thank you just a
couple of
reflections i guess given that this
report's already been submitted
um
on the wastewater disposal issue
i just wondered what work we were going
to do going forward given that um
that under three waters we are likely to
have to convert our discharge
operations from
land to water to land to land and the
report here quite rightly says that
that will require a large parcel of land
and it doesn't seem that within the city
boundaries we have that i just wondered
where we go with that and whether that
would involve some
sort of liaison with potentially the
south and district council as well
so
through you your worship um
[Music]
conversations are ongoing with um the
other councils in bahrain southern and
teomarma but obviously as this paper
notes that we'll move to the
responsibility of the new entity
michael is there any more you want to
add on that
welcome
thank you through yourself worship
just in relation to the
changing compliance standards through to
mata arawa
the standards will
for council were reflected in relation
to our discussions
and baselining for that compliance but
the compliance requirements at the
moment
through our discussions with the
entities will fall on the entities
so we're working with them in relation
to our asset management plans going
forward
so that that the
compliance requirements as we understand
them will be taken through as part of
that three waters transition
and just a follow-up question through
your worship um on the issue of the
closed landfill which is the old
landfills down by the new estuary i just
wonder whether we're engaging with liz
craig our local mp because she runs a um
an environmental group then includes uh
manufenua
about some of the leaching that we're
getting out of that landfill into the
estuary as well
again through you your worship yes
council is engaging with
that group and environments happen on
that issue okay thank you
thank you for the discussion you scan to
the passenger
i'm thinking your worship just falling
on from councillor clark's
comment about the discharge to
of wastewater to land
has anyone got the information on how
many hectares we require
to transform
um currently what we do
i'm aware of what new plymouth is just
going through and it's quite massive
the amount of land they require and then
that would trigger obviously resource
consent use
because not everyone would really want
one of those things
in their suburb or next door to them
through yourself your worship
we have done some initial investigations
but i i do not have that information on
hand to be able to provide to your
counsellor i can seek that and come back
to council in relation to that
council o'clock just as a follow-up
point to what my colleagues raised i
think part of it also it's not just the
size but it's the nature of the land
that you go to
so depending on what their absorption
rate i guess if you pumped it out to
sandy point you'd be able to put more on
per hectare than you would if you had
some other place
but it is a significant amount of land
okay my
second question was regarding um in the
staff report
it talks about
wastewater disposal
and a solid waste it is and that's from
the regional landfill now
i'm very familiar with the
construction of the cells out there and
the stratum the different strata they
use
and the final impenetrable layer that
catches the leap shape which they
suck out and then bring for treatment
now
it just it worries me that
it says it may be subject to
leaking into groundwater now i
i've you know i've i've seen multiple
presentations on that and there is i
can't see any failure of that system but
we're raising it as a a problem and i'm
just
i'm just
weary that we may be out of our
just you know going against the science
of what our provider is actually doing
um
that there is no there is no leakage all
possible leakage
but we're mentioning it here as a
as a worry and i just to me it's a worry
that's actually not real
because that that that bottom layer is
is almost three-quarters of an inch
thick and is impenetrable that's after
it gets through the meter of
um filtering
substances
i just it's just one of these factual
things that
i'm weary of
um raising an issue that is actually not
an issue
through you you worship so um
yes that's why the word may is used and
really it's to draw attention to the
fact that it's not yet fully known what
all the issues are but obviously
this these draft freshwater visions are
for the whole catchment and the whole
catchment is interrelated
but um
yes you're right is about a issue that
may exist but is yet not fully
understood
okay
yeah yeah
no that's fine yeah happy with that
any further questions counselors
yes
fine for the first year or two but the
compounding effect of
continued dumping would have to be taken
into account in such a study would it
not
are you referring like legion into
underground water and things like that
if it wasn't dispersed or treated the
felicia wasn't treated there could be a
compounded thing rising into this
the higher levels above the
protection level that council potential
is talking about so there'd be quite a
bit of science
investigation i would imagine before we
it's progressed with
so again through your worship absolutely
these are all complex issues and this
paper is really just presenting how they
are all complex and interrelated
and therefore the context for while that
why the draft fresh water visions while
they appear simple in and of themselves
have many many aspects many of which are
technically complex
and many of which are not yet fully
understood thank you that was my worry
thank you
happy to move the recommendations your
worship
thank you
seeking your worship just noting
reverend cook has her hand up
yes i was going to say that the issue
with solid waste at the landfill is
possibly not with leachate to ground
water through the
cells but
over surface
so i think whilst the
groundwater
um
through the cell
structure is not the issue it may be
what happens over land so we need to be
aware that there's more than one facet
to this
okay
any further councillor clark yeah two
issues just on the submission that we
made to environment southampton um
and maybe michael can answer this um it
talks on the bottom of the page about
the three waters entity picking up the
responsibility for investment but how
does how do our consent sit at the
moment i understand that the bluff
treatment station is due for consent
before 2024. am i correct i've seen that
steve
2025
25 yep fine that helped that's helpful
and the other issue is
our current progress on
identifying a alternative water supply
one of the worries i have is that
we're one of the few councils in the
country that doesn't have an alternative
water supply so if the arihi river was
um
at risk at any stage we have very little
capacity to provide fresh water and i
just wonder what sort of progress we're
making i know we've been doing some
drilling but is that likely to be
resolved even even it doesn't mean that
we actually have the piping in place but
do we have the sort of test result that
could lead the water entity to
understand that there is an alternative
there because i'm worried that the we
will not be a priority on that issue
when it comes to the overall south
island
and looking across the table
through yourself your worship
there is a report due back to council we
have
completed our first two investigations
so there's a report due back to council
in relation to that
about the emergency water supply or
alternative water supply that report is
due back and i think the next
infrastructure committee
thank you thank you
further discussion questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye
submissions on the smoke-free
environments and regulated
products
smoked tobacco amendment
yes
i just have a question i just hope
someone can answer this for me
it highlights here that it's a smoked
tobacco product only
why isn't chewing tobacco mentioned
like it's more dangerous to the user
than smoking the normal type of
cigarettes that's available so can
anyone answer that can you still get it
no
through you through your worship um so
yes this the spell is very specific and
that it is relating to smoked tobacco
products vaping is covered
in a
in a few occasions
i can't answer the question as to
whether chewing gum is start chewing
gums tobacco chewing oh sorry chewing
tobacco i can't answer that question i'm
afraid
i don't have that information to hand i
possibly can help
so who do we go to
lindsay
yeah counselor
there is a product called nicorette
which uh some of us smokers use to
substitute cigarettes and it has a high
content of nicotine something like four
percent per gum
so that answers that question but uh can
i take the opportunity to actually talk
about what i want to talk about
in this particular
subject um
may surprise you to know that i am
for the most part in agreement with it
being a smoker of some 63 years
and probably having
learned that
nothing else behind the boat [ __ ] i'm
not about 10 or 12 years of age
but the product problem that i have is
that i think the
suggestion that uh 2009 children born
thereafter
not to be allowed to smoke becomes too
draconian and i just can't support that
part of the submission
thank you for that
any further discussion counselors
counsellor
so you worship um several things about
this i guess i really struggle with the
government's trying to go with this i
think they're just they're covering over
a goal of being in new zealand being
smoked 3 and 20 25 that they'll never
get to
it seems to me that we don't know the
true
health
damage potential for vaping
it seems to me that
vaping products have nicotine
added to them which is by nature
addictive so that's the
the smoking industry is going away from
cigarettes and into vaping where they
can hold their clients by way of adding
nicotine into it i understand that
previous attempts by the government to
restrict the levels of nicotine
so that they can be reduced down over
time has not been successful and they've
in effect to some extent turned a blind
eye to some suppliers that have quite
high levels of nicotine in their vaping
products
and and
and so i just can't understand how a
government would want to take away
cigarettes knowing that the health
impact is tar
and i applaud them for doing that um but
they don't seem to be close enough to
actually banning cigarettes at any stage
in the foreseeable future which was
their goal
and then we replace that with um
a habit that's now vaping which has
nicotine which by nature is is addictive
and the other issue is is the issue of
our percentage of people that's smoking
in southam which is nearly 80 18
and i understand that's the highest in
the country
and so that's a worry for us
and i don't think that by reducing the
outlets down from six and a half
thousand down to 500 will change
consumption
because it doesn't matter whether you've
got a shop sitting outside of school
it's not many school kids that have got
30 or 35 dollars in their back pocket to
buy a pack of cigarettes and they've got
that resource they'll go down the road
and get it anyway
and so i just think we're scooting
around the real issues
um
so just just sort of reflection on that
but i appreciate that we had to put
forth some sort of response to it
thank you chancellor
thank you worship just in relation to
councillor ebbett's comment i would just
like to point out that the draft
submission
actually records that after listening to
the views of our youth council
we are recommending that the bill
focuses on taking much stronger measures
to reduce widespread access to and
harm from vaping rather than introducing
age-related limits for use of tobacco
so in fact our draft submission
addresses what councillor abbott was
hoping for and i hope and that
with that additional comment that
councillor abbott can support the draft
submission
after our youth council had given us
that feedback that is what the draft
submission has actually said
i'd also like to comment on the um
submission and that
was
it's aspirational
i know their bill is aspirational
that our young people recognize that not
only is smoking harmful but potentially
vaping can be as harmful or
in some cases more harmful more quickly
and that there is um increasing evidence
of every
impact from that
i
really do think that
decreasing the number of outlets
particularly in areas
of um
access to schools things like that is
not actually unwise we see this in other
areas of the country with liquor outlets
with food outlets where uh
that
and they have house risks attached
i don't see why
this council shouldn't submit
in the hope that
the young people's voice will be heard
as well if they are
recognizing and telling us
we should be listening i think in this
instance because
usually it's young people saying oh you
should let us keep on doing these things
when we're hearing our young people say
we are recognizing this whilst it's
for some it's probably already too late
but those who are
yet quite young
such as my mokopana this is
a um
a timely sort of a decision that we can
make to make difference as for banning
the sale of cigarettes all together
i guess if we're looking at the
percentage of people who smoke now
compared to when i was a child or or a
teenager the the percentage is much less
what we want to see is that percentage
going down and there's more than one way
of achieving that and one is by making
things harder to get one is by not
allowing people to start or discouraging
people from starting so i support our
submission on this matter
counselor crackhead
thank you your worship um i really just
wanted to uh
what um
reverend cook had said um because she
practically took the words right out of
my mouth
and we know that it's a bit of a problem
when our young people are recognizing
that it is a significant or harming them
and that young people are picking up and
vaping
when that would never have picked up a
cigarette and with vaping it's silent
it's extremely harmful the science is
backing that now not only that but
community experience with young people
you know hacking up a lung
developing pneumonia um as there's all
sorts of instances or popcorn lung we
are um you know i'm sure
the counselor would be able to give you
a really uh accurate depiction of how
that occurs
but um when they're turning around and
telling us that their peers are picking
up something that they otherwise
wouldn't have picked up and which is on
par or more harmful than smoking and i
think that we really need to sit down
and listen and the original youth
council was part of
driving our council smoke free policy on
reserves and parks
and this too and the extension of that
um i think is just one of those times
where we really do need to sit down and
listen to youth the youth perspective
um and that is you know
removing widespread excess and
age-related limits they i would note
that they would say that they did prefer
to
limit the use rather than have uh
age-related restrictions because they
felt like it was a bit more of a power
imbalance or the adults telling us what
to do rather than um trusting that we
can make the right decisions
[Music]
well i think your worship i guess most
of the things i was going to raise has
been raised
but
it's very important to note that
nicotine is not not possibly the major
parameter the tobacco itself
the tiles and things like that would
cause the irritant in the lungs and
causes the progressive lung diseases
including lung cancer of course
um but not a new thing that's been
happening for many years in my
profession i've seen many people have
died because of these these conditions
or their general health has been
compromised just from the asthmatic side
effects and things like that counselor
crackit mentioned a popcorn lung that is
one side effect of gross vapor and the
dispense to all propellants in these
vapours
are not
innocent
bystanders they do cause lung disease um
if anybody wishes i can actually flick
on some of the reports i've been reading
over the many years but i won't bore you
with them right now thank you
thank you
thank you
and thank you worship
look i i personally i'd like to commend
the youth council on standing their
ground and and their democratic right to
have a choice
as everyone else has and not be treated
as another group and told what to do
but
what annoys me is the hypocrisy of this
bill and the
and failing to recognize the elephant in
the room which is
that
31
of new zealand's adult population
over the age of 18
is clinically obese
and the pressure that that has on our
health system
far far outweighs anything that smoking
does yet the government
does not go near
this problem
that is hurting everyone and again it's
a self-choice you choose what you eat
you choose what you become you choose
your lifestyle same with smoking you
don't have to it's your choice but
it's ironic that they
they're all keen on the smoke-free 25
yet
we progress
down the road of obesity
and no one is addressing it and the
problems it causes
so
it's just to me this strikes me down
as i would add something
actually
get up and smell the roses and actually
do some proper work
on the health of this country
thank you
councillor sopher again
thank you
your worship i'm sorry i have to correct
the last statement because
there was an investigation into obesity
and type 2 diabetes done
in parliament with 54 recommendations in
the recent past
so i really do have to correct the
statement that obesity is not being
addressed and it is a public health
issue which is certainly being addressed
and will be further addressed by health
new zealand
thank you
i'd like to speak to that and say that
there are no signs of that being
addressed i watched an ad on tv the
other night where lost leader for two
you could buy a liter and a half of
soft drink for two dollars
now you know that's amazing considering
the price of a liter of milk
and you're looking at the limitation of
the amount of outlets for smoking and
stuff like that yet
um
sugar-laden products
are just
uh are so easy to get anywhere and
whatever again it's your own choice
but for what counselor sopra is seeing i
am seeing
no action
at all
in people changing their lifestyle and
clinically obese means that when your
team clinically obese is that your
body weight
actually affects your health
so that's the definition of clinically
abuse
so 31
is not a number for this country to be
proud of
we can probably call it to an end there
and no doubt counsellor
pottinger will have the chance the next
time there is a bill open to make a
submission
on limiting
the sale of
such goods as he is mentioned which has
been given the opportunity in previous
parliamentary bills
um and i'm sure councillor councillor
pottinger can make a submission in the
future
mrs cooper wants to talk please
thank you
i just wanted to
firstly say that um
totally support the youth council's
position around the bill
and also i think one thing that people
forget about is the secondhand smoke
where people there the non-smokers you
know are literally affected in some way
of war
um and so
uh i definitely support the bill going
forward
you
and
all right council o'clock and then i'll
put the motion thank you worship it
would be helpful i guess to have some
end game on this bill if we if we could
know
what parliament was expecting when they
say smoke free by 2025 to me that means
that there'll be no tobacco products by
2025 and people want to vape and have
nicotine in there that they'll have
there but every time i pick up a report
we get slight overtones about
um
about customs picking up illegal
imports of
undeclared cigarettes and everything so
it'd be nice to know whether the
government actually will at some stage
prior to 2025 signal that they're going
to
totally ban tobacco products
um and then we'd know what the end game
was
thank you for that good promotion
received a report
submission on the
smoke-free environment and regulated
products
amendment bill
and confirm the draft submission
put it to the vote all in focus say hi
hi
again
recorded please
um moving on to item 10
i didn't complete it in time for the
agenda
so
come up
excuse me
any urgent business
come on
i'll move the middle report be received
yes
this is the needed version of reading
from
not seeking
that so
your discussion questions
to the vote all in favor say all right
your worship counselor had a question
yes it's regarding um
i see you attended the entity d meeting
which is the regarding three waters on
the 19th
of august i just had a question around
um a couple of key issues with
obviously the other
other members of entity t was um
regarding
the equity around um each member and the
prioritization
of work
are you able to comment on how that was
discussed because
obviously
different councils and and our councils
already made it quite clear in our
submission that we are going to be worse
off
equity wise
what was the view of the other councils
regarding this equity
who else was there at that meeting
i may be able to provide some clarity
but also
no clarity at all and that
they haven't arrived at any solid
uh
arrangement as to what that split will
look like currently
so for every dollar
we currently spend and our ratepayer
spends on three waters we get it back
obviously
so for every dollar we're going to be
putting into enter dd how much are we
going to get back out of that dollar
that policy work uh is looking to be
undertaken in may from may 2022 to first
of july 2023 so you're telling me that
that if you have to create a policy for
every dollar you put in obviously means
yeah
it's either gonna be three choices
you're either gonna get back what you
put in you're gonna get more than you
back
then you put in which i can't see how
that's going to work and the other
option that we're worried about is that
we're going to get less back
now so there's going to be a policy that
determines
what you're going to get back
effectively that's what they're saying
that there's part of the outstanding
policy work that's underway and then
there's also further legislation and
policy change to come
trust me i'm as confused and frustrated
as you are i can't give you any answers
because they couldn't give me any
answers
so
i think
there's not a lot that we can do right
now unfortunately
so really
they have no clue
i know they're working on it we know
they're working on it we are just
effectively in stasis
until they release more information
so does that relate to the
hero the
times article
today saying that the people of bluff
will be
advantaged compared with our situation
yeah it might be able to add some
clarity to this um
about two years ago that was one of the
questions i put to the end um
program director for three waters at dia
and i said look if we're gonna have a
flat rate
for these services across the south
island so each
household will pay the same amount
um
where will you be investing the money in
the short to medium term because that's
important about what council partners
saying when we get back our share of the
investment that needs to be put in
um he said we haven't we haven't worked
that out yet which is what councillor
cracker is now saying two years later
so i then said well is it reasonable to
assume that the main priorities
for investment by the water entity d
will be queenstown wanaka and selwyn
councils who have massive growth
and is it fair to assume also
that because of naitah's influence there
that they are seeking to have small
rural communities that have high
deprivation to also have an upgrade in
their water facilities quite rightly so
that the rest of us will not be getting
much by way of investment in the short
to medium term and the dia said you've
answered your own question
so it's an important issue because if we
invest at the same rate as every other
council and we don't get back any
investment over and above the ones that
we've already talked about which is our
alternative water supply
if we don't get that then when in fact
subsidizing the growth in other cities
or the lack of investment that's been in
other cities so that cross subsidies
quite important
the other the other question was
regarding um
the the shareholding now it's great to
have a shareholding whatever it is
for 50 000 people
[Music]
whatever that means but
entity will end up with the debt now the
estimated debt of
the entire project of the four entities
is between 120
and 180 billion dollars so let's say
population wise any entity might have a
debt of 30 billion
is this council
legally going to have
a percentage of that debt
currently we have a debt of
16.3 million dollars
on our infrastructure
so by moving into entity d will we
have
on our
effectively a debt
uh of of that 30 billion
dollars
a percentage of that
being a shareholder of ndd
well my impression is that it's a
cruel situation we find ourselves in
because
but we're right on the cusp of a
an election
and
[Music]
there's
very um
short notice given to
the people involved
and
including ourselves
counselor clark just to add to what
council pond has already seen no no i
was just asking that question sure yeah
i can probably help answer that um again
asked about two years ago of dia
with department of maternal affairs
um the 185 million across the country is
is not an upfront debt it's to cover
infrastructure investment over a 30-year
period billion it's phased in yeah sorry
1.85 billion
um so it's it's um
it's
spread out over time and of course as
they serve that they'll be recovering it
off us hence the issue of
economy or scale which nobody agrees
that we're going to get and that we will
be worse off than if we stood alone that
excited we'd be better off with the
current assets we got which are 1.2
billion
with a quite a measly debt loading of
about 16.5 million
we'd be better off solving our own
issues and being in with others that are
trying to solve much bigger issues so so
getting back to my very first question
was what was the feeling of the other
councils in ntd
about the equity
can someone answer that
sorry what was that counselor potential
what i was asking is worship who
attended the meeting
what the feeling of the other councils
were regarding equity
uh getting their value back for their
own you know because every dunedin's got
different needs than we have so the
central otago
so the southern district so i just
wondered where where the group of
those people
sat
mayors
and everything
that must have been raised
must have been
so i'm not i'm just asking for an answer
there were people attending a meeting
that
that um
some of us weren't allowed to attend
may i your worship
um thank you your worship um i know you
posed the question to your worship but i
may be a better place to answer it
firstly you weren't
not allowed to go we were asked to send
a delegate and it was a cheers group
that actually decided on who that
delegate was and as deputy chair of
infrastructure that day that i stood in
for you
um it was decided that i would go
um
secondly you're totally right there were
there's a lot of tension in the room
with between mia's
um
who like you have mentioned uh
previously the local government act
doesn't actually provide for us at this
point for us to think nationally we are
dutily there to think locally
um and so that creates a lot of tension
across the room when there's a lot
mayor's chairs uh councillors asking
lots of questions
uh that don't have clear answers for yet
so there's a lot of confusion a lot of
tension in the room one of the questions
that were asked was very rightly the one
that you've asked
of several different ways
several different ways
and we don't get a very clear answer on
that either everyone um we're encouraged
not to think of patch print in a patch
protection manner because like you said
also like councillor clark said uh a
third of um
maori communities don't have reticulated
water systems
and it's statistics like that that in
rural communities that stand to benefit
the most that's been very clear in a
position from the throughout the whole
reform
but
any further than that i can't provide
you any clarity because they haven't
provided us any further clarity so it's
going to be a tax rather than a rate
because the rate
is something that you get back for
services you receive
a tax
is a tax that can go anywhere
ideally we would like for it to look
like that otherwise we're going to have
yet
more mud slung at us from a community
perspective over something the
government has taken out of our hands uh
made us conform to and then if it comes
out looking like a rate we're still
we're still going to get the mud slung
at us for a rate which is typically
associated with a council
but um
councillor pottinger and councillor
clark and thanks for engaging in this
conversation and letting me be your
representative at the zone meeting i
think it's really important that we have
someone at the table at these things
um
i can't yeah i can't provide you any
more clarity than that but i think
because there's so much that is up in
the air i think it would be best that we
leave this for now um and it is off the
back of a mirror report not actually
substantive in
a three waters report so i think it's
best that we do leave the medal eye on
the table because like i said it's i
mean the mayoral report is open to
questions and the entity d1 was a
serious meeting
so i believe the questions are quite
valid that's fair i think i just don't
see any point in us
debating what could happen because we're
we're literally
waiting to be dictated to effectively
now there is again the original
questions were to find out the feelings
of the other
council leaders
with these issues
well i felt that anger
to
worship
i would tend to concur with council
crack at this stage but there are 20 i
think people i'd sorry areas in in
entity range in pombala westland wymati
uh dunedin some of the larger areas some
of the smaller areas to have a consensus
in the competitive short time frame
would be nicely possible to
get
councillor clark just just as a final
reflection
council partner and i went to a um
select committee of parliament in
dunedin last week
and i was quite surprised the level of
um
pushback there was on on the water
entities bill
on
um
we're previously invoking have been
quite vocal about our our desire to
potentially opt out of this reform
and other councils were quite um
critical of our our position
thinking that we weren't a team player
for the whole south island and yet
from my
observations a lot of those councils
have now flipped over
realized the opposition they've got
within their own ratepayer groups
being close to election time and are now
all either opting
against the um proposed bill
or
alternatively are seeking to have a
pause
or a referendum and i think in some ways
our council has led
led the way and others are now following
i'm phyllis harper
thank you your worship i tend to agree
with the councillors crackit and lewis
that the
lobbying for or against three waters at
this meeting has gone far enough at this
point
as councillor cricket has pointed out
and as others have acknowledged there is
a select committee process underway to
which this council has already put in
and spoken to its submission
councillor crackit has given very good
feedback as much as she possibly can on
the zone
six ntd meeting
i cannot see the point of continuing
this
no doubt we will discuss three waters at
some later point but to continue this as
some sort of
anti or pro three waters lobbying
exercise around this table at this point
seems to me entirely
unproductive for this meeting so could
we please draw this particular
discussion to a close your worship
all right
take note of that and counsel arnold
you'll
we listen to a lot of uh opinions and
discussions and bits and pieces but
council ponder's question was just a
straightforward question what was the
feel of in the room at the time it was
just a straightforward question that
really is just an answer required
that's it it's not a discussion about
three waters
as i said
and fearless your worship reverend
cook's been waiting to speak
i couldn't hear that
i said in fairness reverend cook has
been waiting for some time to speak
all right
so
yes so council sophomore her and
councillor lewis and crackit have really
clearly summed up what i wanted to say
this was the mayor's report it was not a
three waters discussion we've spent
considerable time on it and um
i think
in fairness to
everybody
that we should wait until we're better
informed before we discuss it again
yes
although several of the delegates there
were express their anger
i think here's a question
is anyone excited
agent business
[Music]
that the report of the mayoral report
that the report of the mayoral report
be received
secondly
it's been it's been moved by me and
confirmed by his worship
i'll put that now all in favor say hi
hi again
yes i'd like a recorder that i'm against
and the rationale for that is that it's
inappropriate for amir to give us six
months worth of
uh reports in one report
it undermines the ability to ask
questions about what's in the report as
we've now found with councillor ponja
still
voices were raised that
this was the biggest
move that we'll probably face as
as counselors
and
considering the
short time frame
how to allow
that to continue to
urgent business
thank the members of the press and
public for their attendance
here this afternoon
um you wish you just need that moved and
seconded in public
put it to the vote all in favor say
hi again carrie